hello uh were you just in an accident
back
there you
sure yeah over there on uh South H
Street okay do you have your driver's
license and insurance card on
me
I just need to your driver's license
insurance
C yes so you were involved in an
accident just back there we have your
drive we have your your um license plate
your vehicle description you're on
camera and you have damage on your
vehicle and then you just left the area
so we're just trying to get your
information for the accident and then
we'll send you on your way okay so I
just need to see your driver's license
and your Insurance
C girl why is he trying to open my door
ma'am you need to give us your driver's
license and your insurance car abely no
right you have no right to be my father
she trying to ma'am
it's just an accident don't turn this
into something else what accident you
were involved in an accident you you got
to come off of that involved in the
accident you got to come off of that
okay you were involved in the accident
we have to take your
information open your window for US Open
your window what's your first
name don't turn this into something that
you don't need it to be okay all let me
tell you something you're turning into
something Ma'am why did you we need to
take I already explained that to you we
need your driver's license and your
insurance card or what's going to happen
is you're going to end up going to jail
why you pull me over I already explained
do you want me to explain to you for the
third time okay you involved in an
accident on South H Street you left the
scene of that accident we have your
license plate you have damage to your
vehicle we need your driver's license
and your insurance card for the accident
report and then we can send you on your
way if you refuse that you can go to
jail so it's your choice do what you got
to do
I'm just asking for your driver's
license and your insurance card that's
all you got to
do do you have that on
you what accident are you talking about
the one that you were just involved in
now you don't have to keep doing this
okay we can we're going to
continueing okay how about this I need
your driver's license your insurance
card or you're going to go to jail you
pull me for no reason I already
explained to you the
reason so I need your driver's license
and your insurance card or you can go to
jail for obstructing the police it's
your
call are you refusing to open the window
cuz I think you know what's going to
happen if you do that and you don't need
to turn that into something you pull me
over for what you want me to explain it
to you for the fifth time yep CU why you
a't get get on me back then for the
fifth time you were involved in an
accident you fled the scene and now
you're refusing to give me your driver's
license and your insurance card so I
need to see your driver licensing your
insurance card or you'll go to jail for
obstructing the police I'll tow your car
and impound it well you're going to
unlock it for me or I'm going to break
the window you're going to break the
window yeah for what because you're
refusing to give me your driver's
license and your insurance card that you
can't I well I know I can
you so are you refusing to open your
window okay so at this point you're
under arrest I need you to get out of
the car or I'm I'm going to break the
window and take you out why are you
pulling me over I already explained that
you were past that shut the fuck all
right if you don't get out of the car
I'm going to break the window hey ma'am
what you doing here on the scene
otherwise you're you're going to have
we're going to be down at the station
it's up to you this shit is dumb as fuck
okay all right what did that
do it's going to come I've been here for
10 minutes trying to get it
through can you shut the car off at
least so we don't turn this into
something that it doesn't have to
be I just don't want just 10 zero with
to stand around the car
okay thank you can you turn the car off
thank you can you give me your driver's
license and your insurance car what you
think you font of I'm just asking for
your driver's license and in your
insurance card are you dead ass serious
you going to act like that's what you've
been asking me for this whole time what
have I been asking shut the fuck up like
stop okay I need to driver license and
your insurance C it's just an accident
don't
turn so he should tell you then that you
should give me your driver's Li en and
what you right now if you're acting like
this okay why are y'all why do I why am
I pulled over right now for the accident
six time you want to go six you were
involved in an accident you left the
scene I found your car you're damaged to
the front of your car all this is is an
accident report ma'am don't turn this
into anything else that don't turn it
into something else it's an accident
report we need your stuff for the report
and then you're on your way it's your
word against the other driver's word
that's all we we're looking at
man you're making this far too difficult
on yourself I understand on yourself I
okay you just give them your license
your insurance they can relay that over
the other can y'all go to them we
already have an OP with them yeah oh
okay go that's why we're here I a
nothing else to talk about I'm good I
need your drivers like license in your
insurance car I don't have none of that
you don't have your license no your
insurance car I don't have it okay I
need you to step out of the car why
because I need you to step out of the
car because now you're under arrest for
obstructing the police okay you want to
turn that into that we can turn it into
that just get your license get the
insurance get get an ID whatever you got
just provide
it it's
Monday we're not trying to make any more
difficult than I didn't do
anything now you're doing something give
us your license and your insurance card
so we can get this on the report and get
you the hell out of
here
why are you opening my door don't touch
shit I'm not going to touch shit but I
need you to give me your driver's
license and your insurance I am but
don't touch my door why are you doing
that I've explained it to you already it
don't
matter fucking act like so you need to
act like it don't touch shit give me
your dver license and your insurance
card man what a what a you want to take
me to jail take jail don't touch me
don't don't step in my face at this
point just St the side of
the
exctly what you don't grab my
shit got a you got a wrist no got it
Bobby Bobby I'm not letting until you
have
it stop resisting you a dumb bitch stop
resisting ain't nobody resisting resist
you
just you must be a you must be a rookie
you must be a rookie you must be a
rookie the fuck out my
face you feel good you feel good you
still got to
fight
bitch I got I got I
got it's the other other one I got to R
I
got d
23 come on let's
go got to stand up okay stand up stand
up man roll it to your knees and then
come on on your feet come on flip your
on your feet you want your phone this
your phone yeah yeah all right step up
if you want your phone step on your
shoes yall that's fine I ain't do
nothing to y'all that's fine that's fine
put your shoes on you want them or
no I'll put the car stop don't
start you
ain't all right go and get in come
on SE
stinks leave me alone y'all have no
right to arrest me you got to get in the
car ouch hop in let's go man get me the
fuck out of here y'all have no right to
arrest you got to get in I'm going to go
around the other
side come come have to
get come
onru
[Music]
Tony if you can roll a toe for one
please
one yeah yeah we're
good this this all be part of a
defensive uh action reports just to take
down
yeah investigating hit and run okay
she's having a bad
Monday
she I don't know she was going in the
glove box for that
but told a car
for you got came yeah I think it fell
off at some point I was I was just I
didn't know you had one so I was just
sitting there
like here I have a wrist I had a that
I'm try to the over I knew it was going
to come I could just tell right away
I good
job4 you gave her so many commands I
mean having a bad day
yeah all right we'll get her down
there
I'm getting arrested what am I getting
arrested for well you see what you did
back there is like all sorts of not good
okay and I think you know that so just
listen no what am I getting ARR it's
called obstructing the police I mean we
can go a whole different route if you
want with resisting you kick the
sergeant we could do that but we're not
we're not going to do all that unless
you act a fool down in the jail okay so
what we're going to do just listen to me
we're going to go to the Julet Police
Department we have to take your
fingerprints and your picture and then
we're going to release it listen to me
just listen to me britty and then we'll
get you out of here on an ibomb we'll
take you back to or you can go sit at
the Will County jail with no bond
there's your options okay this started
from a simple traffic
stop and and you could have just went
with the program yeah right but you
didn't okay that's
fine whatever so I I'm just explaining
to you why got arrested bullshitting you
could you still be cool but
you I I don't know if that's
true oh well she's probably intoxicated
she was wrestling with us a little bit
she was in an accident hitting run
refusing to get out of the car
so all right Britney so we're going to
take inside finger prints pictures and
if you're cool with that I'll
take take me home I promise you I will
but you got to promise me that you'll be
cool with us we just got to take your
picture and
fingerprints you're going to get a re
today on an hour do that did I do
anything I don't want to go to jail I no
we don't want you to take you to jail
this is just a misdem bullsh
ass so I'm not going to jail no this is
the police station this is promise y'all
not going to put me in jail you're on
camera you're on camera okay I can't lie
to you on
camera I'm
dead fingerprint and picture and then
we're going we got no you're not going
to take off I didn't do anything you're
under arrest it's part of the booking
procedure listen listen to me girlfriend
listen to me y not y'all going to put me
on do not walk your way into a felony
okay don't do what refusing this is a
felony we're trying to get you out of
here we trying